we're cracking this hard drive to gain
access to all the data first we removed
the laptop cover of our decoy victim
extracted the hard drive and connected
to it directly we check the password
using dictionaries this is quite simple
as such dictionaries are formed from
real website leaks and contain actual
passwords let's also try the top 64 most
popular password
distortions H the password is not
cracked then let's use the keyw walks
utility to form passwords let's say the
password is correct next we penetrate
the file system and quickly find a
specific file by extension the key pass
password database using a special script
from the set of a similar program John
we pass the key pass password database
and extract the necessary material for
brute forcing We Run The Hash through
dictionaries and the keyw walk generator
but darn in vain well then we'll compile
targeted dictionaries watch the full
video for
details